welcome to another video
my name is radi and you're watching my
channel riley the brand
today we're going to do a slightly
bigger project using
node.js express and ejs we're going to
be building
a simple news website where the data
comes from an external api
the main features of this project will
include
displaying
the main features of this project will
include listing the articles
having a full view of a specific article
and also
we will add a search functionality i
tried using the news
api.org website support the news data
for the
articles but the information wasn't good
enough
so i decided to use my blog which is
building wordpress
and it has rest api built in by default
saying this feel free to use whatever
api you like
the only difference is going to be the
urls
the parameters and the object names
i think i can't express how easy is to
get started please
we won't be doing much css in this
project as we are mainly focusing
on building the functionality as always
the code will be available
on my website please smash the like
button consider subscribing to my
channel
and let's go
[Music]
welcome everybody let's get started
first of all i have
already created a project folder called
node.js news website
recording and this is where i will be
initializing
the project so if you're in windows you
can do
left shift right click open powershell
window here
and if your mac you're going to have to
be using the terminal
i assume and we have to do a cd to your
project folder once you're here
let's initialize a new project by doing
npm
init and this will ask us a couple of
questions
the only question that i'm going to
answer is the package name
this is basically the name of our
project so i'm just going to call mine
nodejs news for the rest i'm just going
to
be pressing enter to save us some time
and once we're done this is this will
ask us
is this okay and i'll just press enter
again
and this should create the package.json
file for us
in our project folder as you can see in
here for this project
i will be using visual studio code but
of course feel free to use
whatever code you prefer with visual
studio code
you can usually do code space column
and press enter and this will open the
project for you which will save
us a little bit of time but if you're
not using visual studio code
just go to your code editor file
open uh project and continue from there
now that we are here let's open the
package.json file
and quickly have a look at it as you can
see we have a few things here like the
name the version
the things that we just created but
before we start programming we need to
add a few dependencies
the dependencies that we need to add are
axios
body parser ejs and express let's have a
look at how we can do that
in powershell for me here i can just
clear
everything for a second and let's start
installing all the packages now
we can do npm install and we can start
listing the packages that we need the
first one is axios
the second one that we need is the body
parser
then we need the ejs templating engine
and last but not least we need express
press enter once you're done and this
should install all the dependencies for
us
and if you go back to visual studio code
you will see the dependencies being
added here
in our package.json file now the last
thing that
i want to do in this file is to add
nodemon nodemon will basically restart
the server for us
every time we make a change in our
project so that's quite useful
and let's have a look at how we can add
to add nodemon
we need to add it as development
dependency so
to do this we can do npm install dash
dash save dev
and then we can do nodemon this should
take
a couple of seconds as well
and once this is done we can go back to
package.json
and as you can see in here we have def
dependencies node 1. make sure that our
project starts with no mon
we actually first of all gonna have to
create our main file
of our application and i usually call
this app.js
so let's create a new file called app.js
in our root folder
and let's make sure that this app.js
file
is run with node one to do this under
scripts
in our package.json file we can do start
column and then we can do norman
space app.js
then we need to finish this with a comma
save this
and we can close the package.json file
now and start writing our application to
get started
the first few things that we need to do
is include express
and make sure that all express starts
on a specific port number that we will
want in a second the first thing that we
need to do here
is setup or expresser to do this let's
include express
by doing const express
equals require and this will require and
we need to require
express inside here just like so then we
need to make sure that we run express
so we can do comms up equals
express and we need to set a port number
so we can do const
port equals 5000 and last but not least
we need to make sure that our app is
listening
on this port to do this we can do let's
comment it here
listen on port
5000 just like so and we can do
app.listen
and then pass the ports number which is
5000 here
we just pass the variable comma and
we're gonna have
an arrow function in here so we can do
it like this
and for the arrow function all i want to
do is i want to cancel log
listening on port number so to do this
let's do console
dot and with the single slanted brackets
we can do listening on port
and we can pass the port number with the
dollar sign and curly brackets
and then port the pause variable from
here save this
and technically speaking if we run the
project now
from powershell we can do npm
start and if everything is working we
should be getting this green line here
saying starting nodeup.js listening
on port 5000. this is so good so far
but of course if we go to the browser
right now
and we try to visit localhost
on port 5000 you will see that we're
getting this
cannot get and we will get to all of
this
in a second but we're going to have to
set up our project folders first
setup or views routes file shows css
and so on before we do that so no so
let's not rush anything
let's set up a project and do everything
one by one before we do any more code in
our lab.js file let's
actually start looking at the project
folder
and then we will be doing things one by
one so
it all makes sense so first of all let's
start by creating a public folder
and this is where we can store things
such as
css images any other external javascript
that you might use
hopefully we won't have to but just for
example i'm going to create
three folders so let's say we have
a css folder we have images folder
we have a javascript folder
of course i probably won't be using the
javascript and the images
but it's just good to have just in case
you want to add your logo or
some or you want to make your website
look a lot better
then i will now for the css i'm
definitely going to have some css so
let's create
an scss file and i'm going to call mine
styles dot scss i like
using stss just because of the nesting
but of course you can just use normal
css if you wish to
and in visual studio code i am using the
extension
called live size compiler which
will compile the scss into a normal css
so let's do that let's watch for scss
changes
and as you can see this compiled my
styles.scss
into a css file let's close the css
because we're done with this
as i said we're not going to have any
images or javascript but
just for the example let's leave them in
here and
let's now create a source folder which
will be
structured in here in the root so we can
do
source and
inside the source folder we'll have
things such as
the routes views partials and
so on so let's create the first folder
which will be
all views and let's create another
folder which will be our route
and inside the views let's create
another folder
which will be partials
now everything will make sense once we
start creating the
code for this so don't worry the first
thing that
we might want to do is to create a view
and because we are kind of like creating
a news app let's create a file called
news dot ejs we will be using ejs for
or view engine let's now create a route
file and i'm going to
create the raw file with exactly the
same name as the news
but let's do news.js
and the reason for this is because i
think the views
as kind of like or html
and think the routes the news.js file
as the functionality of the news
ejs file if that makes sense so inside
here we can actually start writing
or html just like so and let's
add titles so for example node.js
news and we can actually
include a stylesheet so we can do link
dot css and now inside here
you might see that we're going to have a
little problem
in order for me to go to the public
folder
css and then add my styles.css file
it's gonna take a little bit of
work so we're gonna have to go backwards
then we're gonna have to go
inside the public css and this could be
a little bit of a pain and this is where
we're going to be using the static files
which i will show you in a second
so what i want to actually achieve is i
want to make sure that
every time we put something like slash
css i want
this to correspond to this folder and
if for example we added an image with
the source
i wanted to i want to be able to do
slash img
and then the actual image so i don't
know cat
dot jpg and i want this to be going
inside public images and then cut.jpg
to be able to do this we're going to
have to do this
inside the app.js and in a moment
we'll have a look at the routes as well
so let's go back and
let's set all static files let's comment
here
everything will make sense as we are
going through
so don't worry i know at the moment we
haven't seen anything working yet
but as long as you go into your
powershell and you're not seeing any
errors we should be good to go minimize
this and continue so let's set
up our static files to set up the static
files we can actually use
express static so to do this let's do
app.use
express dot static
and then we need to pass the public
folder this folder here
so in order to be able to use the slash
css slash images or slash js
we need to do the following we need to
do app.use
and we need to then pass the folder that
we want to
the path that we want to use so for
example css and
then we need to actually tell express
static where this css folder is so we
can do
express dot static and now we can
go to the root folder by using the
do name functionality the name is
basically
a middleware function to save files from
within a given root directory
so basically i want to go to the root
directory of this project with their
name
and then i want to add
public which is the public folder here
and then slash css just like so
and hopefully this will now allow us to
write
if we go back here hopefully this will
allow us to write slash
css and then my file is actually called
styles
with an s at the end dot css and
hopefully
this should now work but also i want to
add
images and js just so you have it as an
example to do this i'm going to use alt
shift and down arrow to copy this line
twice
and i'm going to change this to images
like so and i'm going to change this
to js javascript the next important bit
that we need to do is make sure that we
have all
templating engine set to ejs as you can
see here ejs
earlier when we started this project we
did
add ejs if you remember so we can start
using this straight away
by doing the following commands so
inside here let's do templating engine
and to include the templating engine and
the views
we can first of all but before i add
ejs i want to make sure that our view
engine view path
is actually set to this vs folder and to
do this
we can do app.set views
and then i can do comma and inside
single quotes
i can do dot slash source which is the
source folder here
and then slash views and then we can set
the view engine to be ejs by doing app
dot set view
engine and then comma ejs
if you wish to use something else all
you have to do
is change the view engine name from here
so you can use something like perk
handlebars or whatever you wish now that
we are done with the templating
engine we actually need to set or out
and the route that we want to use now
let's do this inside here and i know
that we still haven't seen anything
working on the page
but bear with me we need to set up all
of this and
we are getting close we are getting very
very close
so let's set up the route for the route
first of all i want to create a variable
which will go to the routes folder and
select this news router for it to do
this let's
do a const and i'm going to call my
router news router
and this will be equals required and
then we need to pass
the folder which will be dot source
slash
routes slash news
and we don't actually have to specify.js
express is clever enough to do this for
us now we need to make sure that
our front page is using this router
to do this we can do app dot use
and or from page will be basically just
slash so if you go back to the url you
will see that we just have the domain
name which is the moment like host with
the port number
and we just have basically slash and
this will be your home page and we want
our home page
to be using this news router
to do this we can do comma and then pass
the news
router which we just created here and
later on by the way i will show you how
to create more routes
so you can create more pages and so on
in fact we probably need to create one
more anyway
but we will do that when we need it so
you don't get confused
so far so good we can actually close
pretty much
everything now um maybe
go to news ejs inside the views and
let's just
output something like h1 new
node dot js news just like this
and now we can start writing all router
for the router there is a few things
that we need to do
and let's first of all include express
again
express equals require
express just like we did in our app.js
and also let's um use the express router
so we can do cons let's call this one
news router equals require
sorry this will be equals express
dot writer just like this
and a very important thing that we need
to do
is export this module we need to do
module
dot exports and we need to export the
newswriter
just like so don't forget this line is
important for uh for this to work
technically speaking
we should be able to now use this router
and let's see if we can actually render
the
news.ejs to do this let's use the
news router now newswriter dot
get method i'm not going to pass any
parameters in here we're just going to
do
comma this will be an asynchronous
function so we can do
async and we're going to have the
request
and the response and this will be
a narrow function just like so
so technically speaking now we should be
able to render our news page to do this
we can do resp
response dot render and
then we want to render this news
uh ejs page and to do this we can just
do
news and in fact yeah we're not gonna
pass anything so
hopefully this [ __ ] actually works let's
save this
and finally we should be getting if we
go back to
the powershell uh let's press a button
maybe
c
everything seems to be working um
let's make sure everything is saved uh
yeah everything the nodemon just
restarted i believe
so hopefully speaking if you go back to
the browser and go to localhost
with the port 5000 and we press enter we
should be able to render the
the news.ejs page which will output
node.js
into an h1 and if we inspect the source
of this controlling u
you will see that we have the html page
which we added in here
so that's pretty awesome we have all
routes working
we can create more and so on okay
we've actually managed this so much so
quickly
and now is the interesting part for the
next part
you can use any api that you wish
originally i wanted to use this news api
which is kind of like one of them
popular news
apis or you could use bing as well
but the reason that i didn't end up
using it is because
it doesn't provide very much information
it's a little bit um most of the images
are broken and it just doesn't look
pretty and also
the i think that the only way you could
really use this information is that if
you just list news
and directly link those news to the real
articles
as you can see the content is very short
it's nice and fast for
for learning purposes but i don't know
if i would
use this in a normal project maybe the
paid version has
more content i don't know but feel free
to use this uh
it would be feel free to use this it
would be very similar to what i'll be
doing anyway
i decided to actually use my my
wordpress website
which i know that is not going to be
like a news website but
it's the same principle we have
headlines we have content
we have images and so on and the reason
i wanted to use this
is because the wordpress has built rest
api which provides so much information
and it's a lot more fun to work with
the wordpress rest api you can simply go
to
a wordpress website unless they've
blocked it and you can do wp
json then wp
slash v2 and then for example you can do
the different eight point end point but
for example you can do post
slash and this should bring all the
posts
or at least a few posts uh from
my website as you can see we have so
much more information that we can work
with
i know that some of the articles like
the information
is actually rendered with like html but
this could be actually a good thing in a
way just because
all articles will look a little bit
better than
they would if it was just a plain text
to help us
out i'm actually going to be using a
tool called
postman uh which you can install on mac
linux and uh windows
and postman is basically really handy
if you want to like organize a
collections
of apicals i have my node.js news here
organized and for example
just the thing that i just showed you i
have
for example let's remove this i have the
my website wpjson wp v2
post and i can use anything like the get
method the post method
and so on to test stuff and if i send
this
you will see the output it's a lot like
i'll taste a lot prettier a lot easier
to read
and we can do all sorts of stuff with
this
um and we'll probably you can do this in
the browser as well
or you can use it in here i just like
saving some of the
routes it makes it a little bit easier
and some of the rights that we'll be
using is posts
we have individual posts here with an id
we have a search regardless of
search photoshop and so on so let's send
this
and see the information that we get by
the way this is my website
this link will be available in the
description below
but if you have your own api if you wish
to use the news api
feel free to do that this will be much
faster than mine
because my hosting is a little bit slow
and to be fair if too many
of you using mine my server my crash you
never know
so yeah if you have your own wordpress
website feel free to use yours
or feel free to use this news api or you
can use anything like
twitter medium bing news or whatever
enough talking let's continue by pulling
up some data
now if you remember if you open
package.json we install
this dependency called axios and this is
basically going to help us
to fetch the data from my blog to use
this we can
simply go to the news router
open this and we can include it in here
so let's do const axus
and then we can require by doing axios
inside here like so now to use accuracy
it's actually fairly simple
and fairly powerful and
axios help us with a bunch of stuff such
as
error handling it makes sure that the
data is passed in a json file
and so on but let's have a look at how
we can use it
so we're actually going to comment this
out for now because we won't need it and
let's start first of all i want to
wrap everything into a try and catch
just in case we have
any errors this will be very handy so
let's do
try catch inside try let's pass or
url that we're going to be getting the
data from so in this case
i'm going to be passing uh write the
code okay wp json wp
v2 posts so let's copy this and we can
do the cons and
let's say news api is
equals we can do a weight
which will be asynchronous asynchronous
and we can do ax use
dot get and then we can pass the url
just like so and the reason i'm putting
it into the slack slanted
single quotes is just in case we need to
pass
any data later on inside here
with the dollar sign and the curly
brackets so for now we won't be doing
this
now that we get the data from this url
it's actually super easy to do
we can literally access this data by
doing news
news api and then
dot data and this will grab this object
for us here
to prove to show you that this is
working what we can do
is we could potentially console.log this
so let's do console
the log and inside the console lock
let's do news api
dot data and let's save this hopefully
we're not going to get
any errors now but if we go to a page
and refresh
you will see that we're getting this
massive
array uh which is pretty much this
everything that came up from postman
and this is awesome it means that we can
access this object now
and start pulling some of the data
before we do that though
we need to make sure that we have
something
in place for the arrays so for the
errors let's do
error to be shorter and inside here
we can do if response if error
dot response then we can handle this
in a couple of ways we can do
console.log
error.response.data
we can also do response status
we can also do response headers
and so on and also we can have else
if we can have error dot request
and this will basically handle requests
that were made by the server
and return no response so we can maybe
do console.log.log
and we can have error
dot requests copy this
like so and then we're gonna have else
if something is wrong with the request
then we can do
console dot error
and we can pass error slash error
dot message more information
on axios just go to the npm package
and they have a bunch of other examples
that you can do
but this is fairly solid example and we
should be good
to go in here to start using it we do
have to do
a couple of more things but we will get
to that in a second
if you want to render this data on or
news.ejs what we have to do
is do the same thing that we didn't hear
but passed some data so let's copy this
in fact let's remove it and we can
render it in here so try to get the data
and then
render the data in here so i'm gonna
actually remove the console
log because we won't need it anymore
and we can do rest.render news
news is the ejs page that we want to
render and
we want to pass the object that we want
to render
and we need to pass this data here to do
this
we can do comma and then inside curly
brackets
we can pass it as articles for example
so
because we are pulling articles let's
name it articles
then the data that we are getting from
uh
this so we can do a news api
like so
dot data so hopefully these articles
will be holding
all the data and now we have to loop
through this
using ejs and output some of the
articles on our page
let's have a look at how we can do this
and by the way i could have
created a variable for this but i didn't
think that
it's necessary the code is fairly simple
here so let's just
use it as it is so let's save this and
have a look
at how we can actually loop through this
for this article's
object let's tidy this up as well
like this and type let's go to the views
news.ejs and let's have a look at
how we can loop through the articles so
what i want to render for example this
is
a one object one big object so i can go
inside here and i can start rendering
some of those details for example i want
to render the title
and inside the title we're going to have
to render this rendered title
so let's just remember this and let's go
back and make sure that we leave for
them
we can actually write javascript in ejs
and the way it works is we can open ejs
by doing
arrow and percentage and we can close
ejs by doing another
percentage and the closing array so
inside here
we're gonna have to do a for each so we
can loop
through these article objects so let's
copy this paste the articles dot
for each and then this will be a
function
which will take two parameters first one
will be article
um and this will be basically the key
for looping through each object and then
we can actually
also have index as well if you wish to
so we know every time we loop for an
item we can give it an
index so 0 1 2 3 4 5 but i probably
won't be using this in this example
and then we need to actually cut this
bracket open curly brackets
and let's make sure that we close
everything before we do anything else
so open ejs close ejs
curly bracket close curly bracket is
curly bracket
and close normal bracket we should be
good to go
and now i want to loop through the
articles
and inside articles i want to render
for example the title and inside the
title we have rendit
so remember this some of them we can
just render straight away but this one
the title has a rendered object inside
it
so what we have to do is we can do the
article
dot title dot rendered
and save actually this needs to be
inside ejs as well so let's open djs
like so and put dash on this one because
we'll be rendering
text and let's close ejs save this and
let's have a look at what we get
if we refresh the page
you should be able to see a lot of
titles obviously at the moment we don't
have
any styles but as long as you're getting
the data
this is really good what i want to do
next is spend 2-3 minutes doing the css
the video will be sectioned so you can
actually skip this section
if you're not interested at doing the
css so let's quickly super quickly style
uh something so let's make our website
look a little bit better now
this section is all about the css first
of all let's create a header for a
website
and this header will actually have a
class
of header and inside here i'm thinking
of adding
a like a logo and maybe the search bar
so for the logo we can do diff with the
class name of
header and just go underscore later
and i'm not actually going to have a
logo but let's just do node.js
news and let's
add or search that i hope that you can
hear the noise from the outside
uh for the search bar let's do a form
for the search bar let's do another div
with the class name of header underscore
underscore
search and this is where at the end
we'll be creating our search bar
but for now let's just put search like
so
and save okay now that we have the
header let's save
and see what we get we have the node.js
header we have the search
let's add a few more elements to style
or wrapper
and then we'll jump to the css for the
wrapper i'm just going to keep this
super simple so let's do
a class name of wrapper and i'm going to
wrap
all my articles inside this wrapper just
like so
and then for the news what i'm thinking
of doing is
i'm just gonna have another class name
of news
just to make it look a little bit
different and i'm going to wrap
i'm going to wrap this inside news
just like so so the wrapper will be
global but
this news will be maybe just specific to
this page
we'll see and then for each article
i actually want to make sure that each
article
is kind of like a card so what i can do
is let's do another class name of news
and just go underscore card and do that
and let's wrap the content
inside it just like so
it will make sense in a minute and
actually
i want all the cards to be linked so
instead of a div let's do this as a link
and i'm gonna have to do href now
and maybe for now let's leave this with
a hashtag just so we don't have broken
links
and we can style it and then we'll come
back to all of it i think this is
looking good so
we only have the title let's render
this into maybe like an h3 tag
say let's do let's render some text
so can we do lorem ipsum yes okay so we
can do a lot of mipsum in here and
toggle will wrap
just for example of course we're gonna
get the
original text from the api later and
maybe you will have a thumbnail as well
but
we'll do that a little bit later so
let's save this and let's see how this
looks like it's probably not going to be
pretty
but okay we have all the titles and so
on let's uh make sure that we style them
super quickly
and i'm actually going to do all the
styling right now
all together so let's get on that i'm
going to also i'm going to keep this
super basic
and before we start doing anything else
i'm going to include
a font from google and this font is
called the source
songs pro so we can find you can find
this on google fonts
and let's include that and continue save
this and let's jump to styles.scss
i'm just going to do very basic styling
for this and i will be
super quick so let's get going so for
the body
we're going to reset the margin we're
pressing my g0
let's do the font family to the font
that i just included which is
source suns pro
let's do sans serif then let's make sure
that our background color is not white
because i want to make the cards
uh to white so let's do something
greyish like f6
f6 f6 i probably have six f6 would
i this will do let's save this let's go
back have a look
okay so for the images i'm just gonna
make them
kind of responsive so we can do max with
let's do a hundred percent
for the headings let's make sure that
the font size is like slightly smaller
than the default one so
font size this will be 1.6
ram so then we're not gonna have a
button because the articles will be kind
of like cards
uh so let's not do that let's start the
header now
so we have a class of header and inside
the header
let's because we have two divs if you
remember
we have the div with the logo and the
search what we can do
is display this as flex justify
the content so they are spaced between
so they're like
to the left and the right then align
the items to center then we can do
padding of 10 pixels then we can do
the color to be kind of like white
and then let's add the background color
to make it more interesting to
a nice green color
that i've been using lately and let's
add a little
margin for the so the header pushes the
content below so margin bottom 10 pixels
and save okay for the logo i'm actually
not gonna do anything for this so let's
just start the search for now
and i've already prepared the search so
i'm going to copy and paste it to save
us some time
so basically i'm going to have two
inputs one for the text
and one for the submit button and they
just have some padding
and i've removed the border that's
pretty much it so i don't want to waste
any time on this for the actual wrapper
of the page which is this one i actually
just want to
push the content from the sides here
so we have a little bit of padding let's
do that now we can do this
by just doing wrapper i'm just going to
do padding
of zero one rem which means that we're
gonna have
padding zero top and bottom and one ram
left and right
and that's pretty much it so now
all the news for this for the news part
you can indent as well if you like
uh let's do dot news
um we can display this as grid to save a
little bit of time
so let's do display grid
and i can do great template
columns and i can use the repeater and
then let's say
autofill to make it kind of responsive
in a
min sorry min max will be
360 pixels minimum for each card
and one fraction of the screen
maximum for each card that's good also
let's give it a little bit of gap
between
each card so we can do great dash gap
and that could be to ram it doesn't
matter then for the cards let's just
make them look slightly better than they
are now
so we can do cards on inside here we can
do text
decoration and then because i actually
wrapped
the cards actually links so they are
going to be underlined so let's do text
decoration
and then we can set up some sort of a
color i don't know
um let's do
kind of i kind of want
a black color but i want it i don't want
it to be
too black let's do something like
this this this will do rgb88
that would be fine and then the
background color i want to set as white
and i want to have
each card to have a little bit of
padding so they have some space
breathing
space and last but not least i've
prepared some
drop shadow on hover for the cards so
let's do and hover and add the box
shadow in here
and that's pretty much done for this
page so we can close this
refresh and let's have a look yet okay
this is much much better
of course we don't have any of the
images and we don't have any of the real
text
so let's have a look at how we can bring
the images and
how we can bring the text as you can
also see we have the title here looking
nice
and the search will handle the search a
little bit later on in this tutorial
let's bring the data to bring the data
if you remember we done
article titled rendered and this was
taken from this main object
so we have titled rendered okay so we've
rendered the title but uh
instead of rendering the whole content
here of the article
all i want to render is the excerpt
and then render it so let's do that we
can do this by
copying this line here in fact
and pasting it inside the p tag
let's have a look let's remove
everything
and and paste it inside here so instead
of
article title we're gonna have to do
article excerpt
this is again rendered so let's save
this go back to browser
refresh and as you can see
all the text is now rendered this is
exactly the same text as
if you were to go to my website in this
quick tutorial
in this quick tutorial and this is
awesome let's have a look at how we can
render the picture now of the article
and for the picture
for the image actually done a little bit
of modification to my wordpress
so we can output it in here so if i
scroll down
we can find the thumbnail url in here so
let's
use that as well and i will show you
another trick in a second
so for the image i am actually thinking
of just
adding it in here so img source and we
need to pass
the source just with ejs like
this dash
article dot thumbnail
underscore url and let's close ejs
and let's close the image as well um
but we are probably going to need a
north attack as well
i don't know what to use for the old tag
maybe we can just use the
title rendered like so
and save let's go back refresh
and as you can see some of the images
are probably too big that's why they
it a little bit slower but as you can
see we're now getting the images
which is pretty awesome uh title and
everything is looking good
now if something happened to this api
and it didn't work let's say
we made inside
routes let's say we made the spelling
mistakes spelling mistakes so
i'm gonna put two uh let's refresh the
page let's see what happens
as you might notice now we're probably
gonna get an error
as you can see we're getting an error
here and uh
our website is just spinning and nothing
is happening so let me show you how we
can actually handle this
so what we could do potentially if we
get an error
we could copy this paste it in here so
we still want to render the page
but maybe we want to say articles this
time
we don't have anything articles so we
can say articles equals
no and if articles is equals new
we can check with ejs so we're going to
have to do an if statement inside here
so let's start djs just like so
um sorry it's gonna be if articles
is not equals no just like so
then then we want to proceed and
display all the data but
if article is equals no then we're gonna
have to do
somewhere around here we're gonna have
to do all if statement
else did i close this so i need to close
this with a curly practice but don't
forget
and we can do else close
let's open egs
close the curly bracket just like normal
javascript
and inside here we can put some message
saying
no posts found or something like that of
course you can style this to look a lot
better than you would right now
but hopefully speaking if we save this
and if we go
back and refresh thing is spinning but
let's
i think we've broken it let's have a
look maybe we need to um
cut it they're not found that's good
uh hopefully let's start this again
hopefully if i
now the problem here is that uh if i go
and refresh now
i don't know what the error is the error
could be
inside here or the arrow could be inside
here that
the what was there the error was that uh
right
okay wasn't found so the error could
technically be
inside here so what i could do is
technically copy this
um we still want to render the or
message so let's copy this
three times save it and let's go back to
the browser and refresh
so as you can see now because we're
getting
this error here uh we are actually
checking with ejs if article is new
and then we are rendering no post found
so
instead of so instead of all page
spinning we actually have
something in place for the error the
next thing that we want to do obviously
let's
first of all fix the api call here so
i'm going to remove the two
and save let's go back and have a look
where everything is working and that's
fine now the next thing
we can do is create a new router so when
we click on one of those articles
we can actually view the full
information of the article to do this
first of all let's have a look
at how the wordpress json api works
if we go back the way it
works is every articles has
a unique id and we can actually query
each article with this unique id so if
we copy this id
this has a title of node.js puppeteer
so let me find the correct one and
so for example inside here we have posts
and then we are passing an id so for
pass the id dodge is copied
and get the request you will see that we
only get in one object
and this object is the one that we need
which is the node.js puppeteer
so this is how we can actually use this
id parameter
for the link and get the correct data
let's have a look at how we can do this
so first of all let's make sure that all
link has
this id so what we can do is
inside here we can open ejs
open egs close ejs and
we can do article
dot id as you saw article dot id
here we want to grab that but also i
want to create
we could potentially render the full
article in here but i want to
show you how we can do another route
so what we can do is let's call this
route article for example so we can do
slash
article so this will be the full
article and if we save go back to the
page
and if you hover over here at the bottom
we're not getting the id so
oh okay we're not getting the id because
i forgot the
dash in here so let's save this and now
if we refresh again
and hover over one of them if you see
here at the bottom
we're getting different ids for each
article which is brilliant
and so if i was to click in this
you will see that we are getting article
with this
5372 and now we just need to
create this number with the wordpress
api which i will show you in a second by
doing this basically
and get the information all right let's
have a look at how we can use this id
now to actually query the data
and display the full article
now we could potentially create a
different route
for a single page but i was thinking
that
it might be best just to keep all the
news
functionalities inside this route so
it's up to you whether you want to split
them
maybe if it becomes maybe if your
project becomes too big
you could split the rouse into
route single and route search
and so on but for now i'm just going to
use one and show you how we can do this
so luckily
for us there is not much uh that we have
to do
we can literally copy this we can paste
it in here
and all we have to do is this time
instead of
uh just get nothing i want to add
i want to get this id from here to do
this we can use the body parser to pass
data from one page
to another just like we're doing so
right now
so let's go back to app.js and
let's include the body parser to include
the body parcel we can do this
under here under the express so let's do
cons body
parser and this will be equals
require and we need to require the body
parser
body body dash parser
just like so and we need to add one more
line
to use the body parser euro encoded
so we can do this somewhere here below
our engine and if you want to have a
look at the body parts in more details
there's so many options
but for this example the euro encoded
is probably the best one to use i guess
so let's use that app dot use
body passer dot url
encoded and then we need to do
extend it extend it
and this is equals to true just like so
and we should be good to go technically
speaking
we should be able to get the data now by
using the body path
let's close up dot js and go back
and now to get the id from this
all we have to do is slash column
id and now we can actually get the id
by doing for example let let's make it a
little bit more clear
we can do article id id
equals request dot params
dot id and technically speaking
technically speaking if i console log
this this should give us the id that
we're passing
but there is no point so what we have to
do now is get this number
inside get this number that we've passed
and just included inside here with
the dollar sign curly brackets and pass
article id
so technically speaking that's all good
but i actually want to make and i could
render this
in the news page but let me actually
show you how we can render this
in another page maybe you want the page
to look slightly different
yeah let me show you how we can render
this in another page that can be totally
different
let's create a new page
let's create a new page called news
single dot ejs
and put the new single we can actually
copy all of this
and paste it in here we'll do some
modifications in a second
and let's finish the rest of the steps
so
so we need to change this to be
news single
and let's just quickly copy and paste
and
instead of articles let's make sure that
this is now
this object is called article just
because we're only going to have one
article
i think it makes more sense and you'll
see why in a second
and if we go back now to new single
instead of looping because we don't have
an object
instead of looping through uh object we
can actually
do something else maybe let's remove
pretty much yeah let's remove everything
let's remove everything instead of and
just make sure that let's remove the
image as well
and just make sure that this is actually
still says article
just because this is basically
equals uh this here
so let's save this
and also i'm going to change this to
news
single and let's add a little bit of css
to make it a little bit better news
single
we can do background color fff
max width let's say one three zero
pixels it doesn't matter too much
uh margin we can set to zero auto
and let's just add some padding
everywhere
and i'll do let's close this and the
last thing that we need to do is set
kind of like a
url for this page and to do this we can
go back to app.js
and inside here when we have this is the
front page technically speaking
so we can copy this and we want to have
an article one now
and we can still use the same news
router as we used
above here just because they are all in
the same page
and technically speaking if we save
everything go
back uh refresh and if we click on one
of the links
you will see that we are getting node.js
express cgs layout and we are getting
some of the content
um let me click on another one and now
let's start
populating this with a little bit more
data so instead of let's have a look at
what we have
instead of the excerpt we probably want
to use
the contents rendit let's copy this
and change the article excerpt to
content rendered and i'm actually going
to skip the image
i don't really want the image and one
thing that i notice
is that we could we could potentially
have a link
back to the homepage and i'm just going
to be
a little bit lazy with this so i'm just
going to create a link here
href uh with just a slash
and then we can just say and
lr which is like an arrow in html and
just
do dash back
okay let's save this let's have a look
at how this
looks okay as you can see we have the
link back i'm not going to style this
it's no point uh we have the title we
have the content which is actually
rendered with all the html that comes
from wordpress
it's looking nice of course we can do it
a bit more styling
like some of the buttons and something
like that and
stuff like that but for this tutorial
doesn't matter too much because we're
mainly focusing
on how we can do this so let's click
back and have a look at another article
so maybe we want this express egs layout
article as you can see this is all
rendering nicely
and so on okay
the last thing that we need to do is the
search
as you might have guessed the search is
going to be very similar
but instead of getting data
like here and here we need to post data
and the posting data we can do very
similar to this
but first of all let's explore how we
can do that with the wordpress api
now to search with data let's have a
look at which one it was
to search for data with wordpress you
can actually do
post question mark search equals and
then the thing that you need to search
for
so let's make a note of this first of
all
and paste it inside here and i'm going
to keep
everything to do with news in the same
router
of course as i said you can split it
into different writers if you wish to so
for the news is going to be very
very similar let's copy this and paste
it and
now there are a few things that we need
to do first of all we need to change the
url
so we need to change this let's remove
that
we need to pass the parameter inside
here but before we do that we need to
post that parameter
so instead of get let's do post now
let's make sure that this is now empty
and to pose a parameter first of all we
need to
actually create the form give or input a
name so let's first of all
do that and i can actually
do that in new so let's do a news and
let's do it here and then i'll move
later on so for the form i'm going to
actually just copy and paste
the form to save us some time but the
most important bit here is that
you have a form with an action or slash
and then the method must be post and
also
inside here the important bit is that
for the input
we have the name of search which we're
going to use right now
and the input submit just has a value of
search that doesn't really matter too
much
so the most important bit here is the
action
method of post and the name for the
input of search
so let's save this and have a look at
how it looks like
if you can see here we have the search
bar and we have the search button
it doesn't look too pretty but it will
do the job to get
the search parameter we can now use the
name
to let's actually close everything that
we don't use
and now we need to get the search
parameter and we can do the same thing
as we then in
here we got the id from here
but instead of id let's do body
and let's do search and instead of
article id
let's change this to some product search
and let's pass the search
variable inside here parameter so we can
do
dollar sign curly bracket and inside
here we pass
search to render the results let's do
another page so let's actually copy the
news ejs
everything from here let's do news
search dot ejs and let's paste
everything inside here and because we'll
be looping through
multiple because we'll be looping
through object with
a lot of data we can leave the forage
object in here and we just need to make
sure that
we have instead of article we have
articles
articles articles and articles now that
we've created the new search page
the last thing that i supported is that
we didn't change the render
to news search
so let's do that quickly
and save hopefully if you go back
refresh
and if we search for something that i
might have on my blog
for example photoshop let's click search
you will see that i'm getting two
articles for photoshop
because we copied the stuff from the
news page we actually still have the
links in here as you can see
and i should be able to click on them
and this should lead me to
the arc the actual article so if i look
on this one
this will lead me to the article and so
on so let's search for
node
this comes up with more articles i can
click on them
and they pop up and so on the last thing
that
i wanted to show you is that we could
potentially
use the partials for the search so
instead of duplicating the search a few
times
in here so where is it so in this page
we have this
header search what i can do is cut this
paste it into particles paste it into
partial sorry
new file dot ejs
paste it inside here and we can actually
include this file everywhere now
by doing by opening ejs
include dot partials
search dot ejs and then make sure you
close djs
and hopefully that should bring the same
stuff to the home page so
the search should be still there if i
click on another one obviously we don't
get the search there so let's include it
quickly
i'll copy this paste it on this page
here
where is where is where is it here and
let's do that for the search page which
is
on for the single page as well so i can
just paste it in here
technically speaking now on all pages we
should have the search
let's search for javascript
and this should bring all the posts that
i have
with javascript that's pretty much
everything from this tutorial
i hope that you found it useful please
consider subscribing to my channel it
will help me a lot
smash the like button if you like the
tutorial
and if you find it useful and let me
know in the comments below
what you will be building next with
node.js and also if you have any
questions
please let me know i will see you in the
next one thank you very much for
[Music]
watching